and we say good morning to Craig Sager
TNT TBS and on the cover of Sports
Illustrated who would have thought CEG's
the cover of Sports Illustrated
congratulations yeah I don't believe it
I roots be honest it sounds like an
april fools joke um and even my kids you
know like a flat planet only athletes
and swimsuit models on the cover what he
stood there and I said I don't know but
it was a very flattering as a helmet
article by leads Incans I new Sports
Illustrated was following me around last
week entering that Detroit Cleveland
series and you do an article but nobody
said anything about a cover I thought
maybe you know I'd be hooked up with you
and you're gonna do a fan just my type
or something but a little shocked
obviously very complimentary and
flattering but yeah I don't think it's
really sunk in yet what did you learn
about yourself because when Lee Jenkins
you know dives in he goes deep and I
don't know did you learn anything that
may be surprised you well he went
through a lot of um background and the
article is mostly you know recently
which I thought was very good and I just
kept telling him I could ask me
questions about you know the tough times
I don't talk about oversight over your
article after but I'm dwell on those
I'll talk about you know the days and
the team owner days in the hospital
lights and I like to talk about the
pasta I said only one year on people are
bring up that stuff so i think we ate
you know a dialogue back and forth and
you know you want to know how I've
changed or what's different I said well
okay i don't think i have but it's just
that you know it's a little over
whelming but obviously i understand it
it's not that I'm important it's what
I'm fighting is important I understand
that you know I go to places and
Sabrina's and you know people want to
take the picture you know talk to me and
make them up and you know they said
bration or constrain form you know I
understand it's not just me back to them
on TMZ but it's a bigger cause
everybody's been affected seems like
some way or another by cancer and they
want to see somebody fight this stuff
it's the evil and the as long as I stand
up and I keep sweating it and then don't
give in and you know I go to the
hospital and night before a game I get
all my blood work so I can get to the
game and do it they find inspiration of
that so it's far beyond me it's a
because I'm playing forward I just had
to be a symbol of it and you know it
didn't help an article and like I said
it still really hasn't sunk in that you
know my cover of Sports Illustrated you
gotta be kiddin how's your health now
I'll pretty good except nobody knows
here cuz my platelets for so long I
won't stop bleeding sunglass the phone
interview that TV but didn't you have
that before when when real sports did
the interview was your nose kept in a
bloody nose India yeah what happens is
when your platelets get low your blood
doesn't coagulate and stop so any type
of a cut you can bleed to death and so I
get this in my nose um so I'm sitting
there with a little cotton ball but look
like a fighter well you are I kept this
one good horror fighter we're talking to
Craig Sager tnt and TBS how much does
working help with this whole process oh
my gosh oh my gosh can't believe how
much it else you know you know it's
funny sale those days and see that and
you know it was at work is you know it's
our livelihood that's what we do and
just the fact you know they get to you
know go to work and do things I mean if
I had to just lay around and you know
you'll starve myself because I had a
blade nose because my platelets are low
I mean it would drive me nuts and dry
Stacey nuts and it certainly would not
be any inspiration or anything to be
fighting for I just you know finished
the Detroit Cleveland series which is a
sweep seven here in the office I went to
the Boston Atlanta game from fun last
night and then
that's waiting for my assignment and I
just got the word this morning I'm going
to be on the okc San Antonio series
which is perfect because my hospital my
doctors are all in Houston soon I mean I
could literally drive from San Antonio
over there so have to go in twice a week
give blood so I think that's perfect to
level build I won't have to miss a game
I can still do my job so it works out
great it certainly is therapeutic and it
certainly gets me going and you know I
love it no without it we have very very
very massive void my life in you know um
be it'd be really difficult the process
of giving blood explain it well I go in
and they take my blood and then they
have to cross match it which is uh just
to make sure that when I have a
transfusion medicine exact match so it
takes about two hours and then when I
keep in monday i know i was running low
that's serious so they had to give me
two bags of platelets and that takes by
an hour piece and then i had to have two
blood transfusions and they're anywhere
from an hour and a half to two hours of
peace and it's not one of those things
we instantly feel great but if you
definitely feel like you got a little
more strings of them more stuff in your
stuff and you know you can kind of feel
down when you can kind of feel when
you're running low um you know you got
your car you're driving it and gas tank
says you know what can we help you find
a gas diction you're just still driving
the car me you're not gonna let so fast
that you're kind of like worried about
running out so it's a it's a physical
you know thing you need keeps me going
accuse me alive so it's just a minor
inconvenience that I have to put up with
a couple times a week I've known you a
long time and when people say Craig
Sager oh he's the guy who wears the
outfits and then I started to wonder do
the outfits actually overshadow your
abilities like I mean you're determined
fearless sideline reporter
and it feels like people notice the
outfits more than what you're really
doing as a job did you ever process that
and wonder if it's sort of overtaken
what you do in your talents yes dad
Zefram head father of yeah yeah Hey well
I mean it as a compliment those eggs Hey
no I I know you're saying but son used
to say that I would just like myself and
family with north-westerly already
invited realistic you know degrees
either yeah count that down basically
thought of that I don't feel comfortable
and just don't you come to walnut
anishia mad at me so yeah some people
said that to me um but like you said if
you don't mean it's it's like that fun
like to be lively you know we're going
down the chattahoochee river her I'm not
gonna be wearing a great t-shirt blacks
with that I can have on sand you know
loudmouths swim trunks or something
Lively we had fun of those chattahoochee
river trips we did the keg oh my god I
don't think you're supposed to have a
keg on a raft but we did right yeah we
did yeah and I don't know there was
anything left in the keg when we were
done with the Chattahoochee River I know
and I don't think we got to do it today
I mean this is more pollution to that
River now than ever we didn't care back
then those eggs I I did tell the story
yesterday with Paulie Paulie was with me
remember when we were outside the
clevelander and and we were arguing
about the heisman trophy voting and it
and it got rock really heated yeah yeah
yeahs polo yeah Paulie was there my
producer and and I'm and I'm thinking
like who who else is going to go
toe-to-toe to talk about heisman voting
because i think it was adrian peterson
at the time i'm saying he's the best
player in college football and he won't
be considered for the Heisman so we had
a couple beers in us and here we are
right at the corner on at the south
beach and the clevelander outside i'm
going oh my good Paulie goes I thought
it was go time with you and Sager and I
go I did too and we're arguing over the
damn heisman trophy voting
whereas I think it's unlike you don't
want to vote cuz it was a sham an
automatic yes yes and now I'm voting and
now I do include freshmen and sophomores
in here and we've had them win the
heisman zeg so i was right i think is is
what I what I'm so you imagine if we
fought though on the corner of south
beach that night ah I've been like one
of those fights in the basketball court
wouldn't last long oh you think you you
would take me to be over quickly no I
think better heads would prove that all
they would okay well that's why I had
Pauly there to be able to separate us
just in case Paul II would have probably
let it let us go like I'm not gonna
break it up go ahead hey well congrats
on the story it's wonderful and you know
i guess i'll see you in Rio you're gonna
you're going to cover basketball at the
Olympic Games yeah yeah should be fun I
guess it's a I told him you know what's
weird about the obviously chemo have to
get every month at all but if they've
arranged it they they've already talked
to him the Anderson my hospital they
said I get the best care for the
athletes and I'll be able to have access
to the same care they have so that's not
weird at all awesome awesome all right
well keep keep doing the great job
stirring it up there and I'll see you in
a couple months you got it thank you
sexy all right that's a Craig Sager TNT
TBS the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience